[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the columnist
carol malone and the political editor of
the liverpool echo liam thorpe they'll
be with us from now right up until just
before midnight so let's see what's on
some of those front pages for you now
reacting to the resignation of the
metropolitan police commissioner the
metro has the headline cressida ditched
the eye also writes about the met chief
losing her job after a succession of
scandals
that same story features on the front of
the daily telegraph
the guardian adds that she has been
forced out over toxic culture failings
the times also writes that there is a
scramble for new met chief after the
abrupt resignation of dame crester dick
the daily mail tells the same story
asking what took so long
the daily express focuses on the queen
coming into contact with prince charles
two days before he tested positive for
covid
the ft looks at the government's plans
to overhaul financial regulatory
practices after brexit
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and tonight we're joined by carol malone
and liam thorpe welcome to you both
let's start uh with the story of the
night and the front page of the metro uh
kresta dix resignation carol expected
yeah you know not really i mean it
should have happened a long time ago but
not expected in the sense that it was
only this morning that she said she had
absolutely no intention of resigning and
this was after sadiq khan london's mayor
had put her on notice that if she didn't
sort out the toxic culture and the met
police that should be fired and there we
have at the end of the day where she she
suddenly says yes i will resign i mean
this is long overdue you know after the
sarah everard murder
um and it was
murdered by one of her officers wayne
cousins um she should have gone in
because because especially because
confidence in the
women's confidence in the police had
been destroyed by that and she should
have gone but then she was offered
another two-year extension and i don't
know why because since since the woman
took office
there has been a catalogue of disasters
you know ranging over years you know
operation midland this you know the
extinction rebellion
they took over london they brought the
city to a standstill the officers
couldn't handle it she didn't she didn't
know
the serial killer and stephen port he
wasn't um arrested they missed many
chances to arrest him if she just is not
fit for purpose she should never have
been in charge of the capital's police
force never
liam um it does make you wonder what she
submitted to the mayor her report by way
of wanting to to change things and her
plans for the future because he
said that that absolutely wasn't uh up
to standard
yeah as carol said um you know earlier
today she was she was quite robust in in
saying that she was she had no intention
whatsoever of stepping aside she then
obviously
submitted whatever her plan was for for
improving things to sadiq khan and he
was clearly deeply unimpressed by by her
effort he then made it clear that he
made it clear how he felt about that and
summoned her to a sort of showdown
meeting but rather than go to that
meeting it's reported that she then just
handed in her resignation and so it's
like she sort of knew the writing was on
the wall in that sense but it's not
clear that sadiq khan was going to
sort of force her out at that point but
she chose to sort of go before perhaps
she was pushed it's an interesting kind
of dynamic that's going on here because
sadiq khan is the mayor of london has
effectively withdrawn his confidence and
has has sort of been the kind of final
nail in the coffin for quest of the day
but it seems like the home office were
were not really aware that this had
happened and it kind of came to them as
a bit of a surprise although they are
now the people who will will hire a
successor so it's a sort of strange
separation of powers uh it's it's all
part of the kind of mix of devolution
that we don't quite always know how it
works um but yeah i i mean i would agree
with carol i think that the catalogue of
scandals and and and errors is so long i
was i was going through them before and
it's a it's a really really long charge
sheet if you will dating back you know
all the all the way back to the the
situation with john charles de menezes
where of course christopher dick was the
the operational commander of of that
mission of that tragic mission that um
and obviously the family of john charles
and menezes always said that they didn't
think she should be
made uh commissioner i think the same
has been said for the family of daniel
morgan who uh questioned it was greatly
criticized for delaying that
investigation and then as carol says
obviously the sarah everard both the the
the situation with her tragic murder and
the the policing of the vigil those
awful scenes that we saw and then more
recently this cheering cross
investigation which really highlights
that toxic culture um within the met
removing quest of the dick isn't going
to change that overnight but you have to
start at the top with these things if
you really want to get root and branch
reform the vi uh suggests that her day
didn't end in the manner in which it
started at 11am her quote is i have
absolutely no intention of going after
nine minutes past seven this evening it
is with huge sadness that i step aside
um does this suggest that that she has
something of a a tin ear or
definitely displayed those qualities in
the job she doesn't seem to have been
aware of the culture and some actually
accusing her of denial
julia i think you're absolutely right
you know even today when she was talking
in an interview she's she doesn't see
the reality of what's actually happening
in her force she said today that the met
had undergone a transformation that it
was more professional more transparent
more accountable it's simply not true
the the met isn't a mess and i think i
think the final layer in the coffin has
been
what's been happening over the past few
weeks you know
many weeks ago she said she wasn't going
to investigate the damn extreme parties
then she changed her mind and at the
time she's doing that her force is
imploding you know she's she's invested
she's conducting 50 interviews with
people who work at whitehall about these
parties at a time when officers in her
force are being accused of racism and
sexism and homophobia and she's not
dealing with that she's dealing with
offenses in downtown which is violent
disgusting as they are they're they're
going to end at a few fines and fix
penalty notices what's happening in her
force is far more lethal and it's like
she was blind to that she kept on saying
things were going to change she was
going to do things but she never ever
did and i think you know as liam says go
right back to 2005. it was kind of clear
then after after
an innocent man got shot because of her
incompetent officers it was kind of
written then that she wasn't fit to be a
leader but then she's gone on to be
you know the first woman gay woman
leader of the metropolitan police and i
think you know part of the reason that
it's taken so long to get rid of her is
because she was the first woman and they
didn't want to be seen i mean every time
i used to write anything critical about
crested a dick there was a there was
there was a hardcore of people who would
say you're a misogynist this is about
woman this is because she's a woman no
it's not it was because she was pretty
useless at the job and maybe that's
given her
time that she shouldn't have had she
should have been she should not have
been granted this two-year extension she
should never have been offered it but
you know we are working on liam do you
agree with that do you believe that she
was kept in post because she was a woman
i don't know that's difficult to say
obviously it was it was an important
moment that a woman was made the first
chief comfortable the first commissioner
sorry that is an important moment and i
think it would be good if if a woman
could succeed her um i don't know if
that's bought her extra time um just on
the on the party gate issue that carol
mentioned um i think let's not forget as
well i think she's dramatically
mishandled that as well or the met
certainly have you know it wasn't too
long ago we were being told that um none
of the the potential offences or the
parties in downing street could be
investigated because they happened a
year ago everybody knew that was
absolute nonsense and then it quickly
quickly had to sort of reverse ferret
and when they did that it interrupted
the sue grey investigation there's a lot
of questions now hanging over how that
investigation into the dominant parties
continues it's it's a real messy
situation and they'll they will want to
bring someone in quite quickly um but
yeah and i think just fundamentally you
know
ordinary people have lost confidence in
in her and and in the force that she
runs and with you know as sadiq khan
said today we do we do police by consent
and if the people have lost faith in her
and her ability to to change things then
you know she's going to have to go and
that will be the major challenge to
restore confidence we're going to have
to go to a break carol um do stay with
us of course coming up a frosty
reception for the foreign secretary in
moscow that and major criticism from one
prime minister to another when we come
back
[Music]
just want to bring you some breaking
news now on the situation in ukraine and
this is a from president biden who says
that american citizens should leave
ukraine now
it's actually quoted as saying that
things could go crazy quickly in ukraine
um and also he says we would not send us
troops into ukraine to rescue americans
who might
be fleeing uh he says he would not
sending troops just to redirect that
into ukraine to rescue americans who
might be fleeing the situation
there
and
biden also says he's done a deep dive
on
our four potential supreme
situations that might arise out
of that situation in ukraine with
100 000 russian troops amassed on the
border so president biden's saying
that things could go crazy quickly in
ukraine and u.s citizens should leave
now
you are watching the press preview and
uh still with me carol malone and
liam thorpe um so you heard there that
very latest from president biden uh
extremely worrying what he's had to say
to us citizens meanwhile
we were going to have a look at the
telegraph and the visit of this trust to
moscow
it couldn't have gone any worse could it
liam
no i don't think any of us were
expecting it to go particularly well um
you know and
lavrov has not um often sort of
heaped praise on on on western uh
compatriots when it when they've met um
he's described liz trust as as deaf as
unprepared he mocked her about her
geographical knowledge and she's she's
sort of hit back and and and claiming
that that she is she's had she's
achieved more in this meeting than he
certainly suggests but it it it's ended
in complete enough to stalemate it
hasn't got anywhere because ultimately
there is there is very little movement
to be had you know
and the the west
and nato are not going to accept
russia's demand that that ukraine cannot
join nato and and russia is not going to
back down from that it would seem so
unfortunately today's meeting um did not
achieve anything whatsoever um and and
instead we were hearing from from
president biden we heard from boris
johnson today you know a real kind of
ramping up of the of the warnings and
the rhetoric boris johnson said uh we're
on the precipice and as you say as you
just said then joe biden has said things
could go crazy quite quickly analysts
and and people who know the situation
well have said that you know that russia
perhaps is is now moving it's now very
close or after situation where it could
potentially
invade and that's obviously just a
disastrous thing for for everyone
involved
uh carol just got about 30 seconds to go
to the metro and uh john major and what
he's had to say
ah yes this is one of the most
unremarkable prime ministers of all time
coming into uh attack breaking cover to
attack boris johnson um you know it
makes you wonder he's so embittered and
angry about his own pitiful record as
prime minister that he's attacking
someone else's one commentator said
today watching him attack johnson he's
like watching a tiny go for his square
up to a blue whale he just looks like an
embittered failed politician and this is
not about partygate this is about brexit
this is this is an oddbridge regulator
sorry this is an arch remainer coming up
again because boris did something that
he didn't want to happen he achieved
what people like major said was
impossible and he got us out of europe
and major wants to reverse that and i
think he'd rather say ks dharma
who wants another referendum rather than
boris
uh and liam there are those who would
say but uh perhaps uh john major was
never accused of being a liar
well john major
carol's right in one sense john may has
never been a fan of boris johnson and
it's not a surprise perhaps that he's
spoken out against him but what he said
was really powerful today he said that
if you are a liar if you've lied to
parliament you should resign it's pretty
clear to most people that when boris
johnson said there were no parties no
rules broken that was not true so he
you know